all right guys the one that i think john
is actually the most anxious to check
out
i'm really excited for the potential of
this series the marvel's
what if let's finally see the official
trailer baby
[Music]
it's a prism of endless possibility
that doesn't sound ominous at all
looks like a standard there it is there
it is
damn challah star-lord
right i think so yeah now one of the
announcements
[Applause]
fascinating
[Applause]
all seem too freaked out about all this
kid
doing out there all by yourself anyway
exploding the world
sounds fun let's pick him up from the
condos
oh wow
[Applause]
that jeffrey wright's voice
[Applause]
oh
i wonder how far they'll go
strange versus strange
oh we gotta do reactions to that one
that looks so much fun we gotta do
reactions to that that looks some it
looks awesome like this
i love the animation yes that was great
like it's great it reminded me kind of
that like rotoscoped
a scanner darkly kind of you know
approach but more developed to the point
where especially in some of those wide
shots it literally looks like concept
art come to motion life you know
exactly with a bit of like an anime
aesthetic touch
infused into it as well i mean you got
the captain america zombie
dual strange and you got t'challa as
star-lord you got peggy carter as cap i
mean i'm sure there's like more
little tidbits here and there i think
that was jeffrey wright's voice as the
watcher
it sure sounded like him i would not be
at all he's a very distinguished voice
i mean i could listen to his voice all
day well he's probably an actor who like
if you look at his imdb i would not be
shocked at all if he does
way more voice work than you'd ever have
realized because he has
but that's also one of the potentials of
this show that makes me excited is not
only to hear who might come in and voice
a character out of the movies that we
already know but also what other
great actors great voices great voice
actors might
come into the mix as well who might be
able to take a crack at a character
who's maybe
had their stamp put on by a certain
actor giving us an alternate take or
whatever like possibilities are endless
i mean
the actors had come back and and that
was really great to hear
uh t'challa's voice again yeah that was
really touching you hear his voice again
what i love too is that they designed
all these characters to to the likeness
of what they look like in the movies
because it could have easily just stuck
with going closer to what they look like
in the comics and such or
specific comics but they clearly
designed them to look like the ones from
the films and i love that approach as
well yeah especially during this phase
where everything's so connected it just
feels appropriate
i mean yeah this would have to be
chadwick boseman's last mcu appearance
holy crap yeah
holy crap that really was amazing to
look at yeah i want to be nice just to
hear his voice in the character one more
time you know and i wonder how
far they'll go with marvel zombies oh
dude i mean like that seems like the
kind of thing where if this grows and
goes beyond one season you could
do that once a season i mean because
marvel zombies already has its own
niche following they're probably not
gonna go too violent but they can go
dark and mood and tone at least you know
a lot of them
wish you could go i want them to kind of
go all out on that anyway guys what'd
you think of this first look
at uh marvel's what if um i thought it
looked pretty
pretty [ __ ] awesome my girlfriend was
pretty cool
very excited all right hit that
subscribe button click that notification
about let's see what else is on store
today we're gonna do that bad batch
trailer
[Music]